it's time for us both to get in gear
because today marks the beginning of
SEMA it is one of the world's biggest
Automotive trade shows if you're not
familiar with it we're going to show you
all about it Candace Charles joining us
live at the convention center she's got
a sneak peek good morning Candace
good morning YouTube good morning folks
I really feel like I'm turning into a
car gal I'm so excited to be at SEMA and
we're right now in the North Hall and
this is just one of the holes that's
filled up with everything automotive and
I'm joined by sema's top good too so I
did almost I almost was right guys I
practiced his name and now I got it
right I'm pretty I'm pretty proud of
myself thank you so much for joining us
this morning right now we're in SEMA
Electrify I know it's been all about
electric vehicles for the last couple
years where people can see a bunch of
stuff here what people expect to see
yeah we're everything for the automotive
industry from performance to racing to
repair to electrification so if you're
into the automotive industry this is the
place to be now I know you guys are
going to have a bunch of different
brands here we're going to be talking to
Nissan coming up so that's exciting who
else can that trade show folks expect to
see well we've got things or companies
like Dodge and we've got Toyota and
Lexus and Mopar so you really can see a
wide range of oems but also the parts
manufacturers really shine at this show
so anybody that makes them something for
a car is going to be here awesome
awesome okay so I know that this is for
trade show folks but on Fridays open to
the public how exciting is that and what
can people that aren't so much into the
industry enjoy so it is open to the
public on Friday and we do that through
SEMA ignited which is an after party or
an after-hours party that we do on
Friday but they can see really
everything from the automotive industry
so any part of the industry that you're
into we're going to have here and this
is where the future is so it's not just
what's on cars now but this is what's
going to be on cars in the next three
five or ten years awesome time thank you
so much for chatting with us this
morning we appreciate it so much to see
of course a trade show opens today again
it opens the public on Friday tickets
start at about a hundred dollars we have
those details for you on our website
eightnewsnow.com coming up you guys will
see me get into some vehicles and do a
little bit of riding so check that out
you won't want to miss out on eight news
now but for now live from the convention
center where sema's gonna be taking
place I'm Candace Charles 8 News Now